what's going on you guys Lord addicts
here I'm here with Jacob from draxi
games we're coming up at you with the
iron Lords podcast Lords of gaming.net
so first off what kind of game are we
looking at here you know tell them tell
the room a little bit about the game so
yeah we're making a retro inspired jrb
cheat uh it's called ulterium shift it
features three main Heroes who each have
their own branching story paths uh and
you can think of it like you're playing
the game from the perspective of your
chosen hero those stories kind of break
up at the beginning and then come back
together for a glorious uh story uh
telling towards the end there so when
when you say like stuff like that first
thing I go to is like the Pokemon the
rivals like when it comes to the
characters splitting up is there any
specific reason you split them up
because they're like branching Pass that
might make them do different things or
maybe someone turn into a villain or
something is there any kind of thing
like that we can look forward to and so
the main Drive behind the characters is
that they are heroes in training yeah so
they're uh teacher dolian is training
them in the ways of uh you know just
trying in combat and trying to teach
them to fight this evil which is the
dark elves who uh 50 years ago there was
a great war between the Dark Elves and
the humans and so during that conflict
uh and towards the end the humans won
and so uh they are now just training for
any kind of potential comeback of those
uh Dark Elves uh he sends them out on
various missions that's why they split
up and go in different paths because
he's trying to find the one okay and so
each character you play actually ends up
being the one through that story path
yeah so kind of like something like
occupied Travelers where it has unique
perspectives through every character so
I'm looking at the art style it's very
unique was there any inspiration for
that kind of reminds me of like oh final
fantasies yeah so the pixel art itself
is more inspired by like a secret Amana
uh but the gameplay is more inspired by
like Final Fantasy six and Chrono
Trigger we have a turn-based battle
system uh you can't think of it like
octopath traveler where there's a turn
order display you can pre-plan your
attacks and whatnot so you know this
type of gameplay has been done a few
times is there any perspective that you
went to to different this kind of
gameplay from you know the competitors
that's happened in the past so our our
rule of thumb from the very beginning is
for very retro focused a lot of these
games they do add a lot of really neat
uh systems to it we kept it more basic
uh and kept it more true to the Retro
style now we are working on some of our
own unique uh systems that we're just
not ready to show yet but you can look
forward to during our ea uh Early Access
well I think one of the biggest reports
you can see right here is the unique
characters you know these games you
don't really play as three different
characters it kind of gives you a base
character you go into right and that's
pretty much how it is so I think right
there you can you know take the
perspective
guys are branching this out to a
different one right right yeah so yeah a
lot of the times uh even with other
games you don't really even see a
cohesive storyline uh we really want to
work that in with these three characters
no matter who you start with that story
always comes back together it's very
cohesive between them that relationship
is very important as well yeah I hear
you know what's good about these is I
feel like Indie developers keep these
type of games alive you know a lot of
the bigger Publishers don't really focus
too much on this and that's what I
really saw this and I really gravitated
towards it because I like these style
games I feel like they do really well at
telling a story they have solid gameplay
but you know what else do you want to
tell the realm when it comes to a
learning shift
uh so uh basically the um you know if
you are a fan of these retro Classics
just like you said we are looking to
keep that feeling alive Nostalgia was
the factor that we were looking for from
the get-go you know we wanted to trigger
you you saw this game oh yeah I remember
Corona sugar I remember Final Fantasy
six I remember secret Amanda I we wanted
to just basically invoke that feeling of
nostalgia instantly no I don't know if
you're willing to tell this but how many
hours say it would take to complete a
playthrough of delirium shift so
currently uh our demo is an hour long
we're looking to extend that play
through uh for about three to four hours
for the Early Access period the final
product we're looking to do about 10
hours per character so yeah about 30
hours if you decide to do all three
character paths which we will have
incentives for you to do well you know
it was a pleasure meeting you Jacob from
Zara games uh you know everyone
definitely check out this game we're
giving you plenty of content epoxies and
until next time this is Lord addict
we're signing off lordague.net and the
iron Lords podcast you guys have a good
day